all right gang dave baker here and i
finally get to answer some of the fan
questions so here we go
i love weapons very much but i also cook
a lot and i just wanted to know where
all these sliced up meat hunks go and
how much of them go to waste
well all those pig carcasses
boar carcasses those all go to a wolf
sanctuary in upstate new york
when we cut up the salmon that usually
gets filleted by myself and goes in my
refrigerator
where did you get those bleeding
mannequins
so our bleeding gel torsos those
actually come from our art department
what they do is they take a plastic
skeleton and they pack that full of
rubberized organs and blood packs then
they pour ballistics gel around it in a
mold and let that set up once that's set
up those are our gel torsos now that
took a lot of time and research to make
those molds we go through them like
there's no tomorrow but our department
does a great job setting those things up
i have a question about the nagamaki was
it effective at blocking i mean it's
really quick and really sharp but it
seems kind of flimsy and might break
easily
i'm not really a person with a big
knowledge on weaponry so please take it
easy on me
the nagamaki is sort of a oversized
katana blade with a handle almost the
same length as the blade
was it commonly used for defense as well
as attack and yes it's a both an
offensive defensive weapon if you're
going to get into a fight in feudal
japan you you probably ought to have
something that's both offensive and
defensive and when used by somebody who
has studied that weapon and understands
how it works in all its forms it's a
very quick weapon
i don't know if william wallace used a
claymore at the battle of falker
no
i don't know either
there are a lot of legends about william
wallace and what he carried the sword
that is on display in scotland
probably wasn't his i i know some people
are going to call and yell but there
were great swords in the period but the
design of those swords doesn't quite
follow what was necessarily used maybe
in the movie and or what is on display
in scotland
don't get too mad at me
is this right-hander not simply a
flambearist or is that just the type of
blade
so is this why handler we had on the
show a flam bearish yes the flambeers
refers to the actual blade on the thing
you can have a flying batteries rapier
you can have a flamberries broadsword
you can have a flammability whatever you
want flam bears just means flame-like
and so yes ours by handers or flambears
what's the difference between a hussar
and a messer
a hussar is a position in the military
they were horse cavalry the hussar sabre
is a curved saber a messer
is actually a blade there's the kris
messer grossmaster standard messer and
it's basically a chopping blade it
usually had a knuckle bow a small guard
sometimes a pummel sometimes not so
what's the difference between a hussar
and a messer who saw as a person a
messer is a sword
[Music]
you